you know schiller at Yale wrote a book
that's his name and told us that we had
this huge real estate bubble I I didn't
read the book but I I knew what he was
saying an awful lot of people knew about
it I the way I look at it there's no
single cause this event as horrendous as
it is took an awful lot of people
working hard to get us there it's bank
supervisors not doing their job its
directors and management of financial
organizations not doing their job it's
Congress not doing its job with Ginny
Mae and Fannie Mae I can go on and on
with a large list it's the securitizers
who were securitizing you know it had no
skin in the game in terms of the loans
they were working yet it was the
investment banks who would specify the
nature of the securitized products and
what those loans must call for it was
the rather slimy inch the brokers for
real estate lending and mortgage bankers
it was snl's federal SNL's who would
have these transactions go through them
for usury purposes who really didn't
care what the transactions were it just
it just goes on and on the Fed interest
rates too low so it it it's really i
think inappropriate to say it's any one
person when I think it's a systemic
event and that's what we have is a
systemic event you know it's really
society is to blame not any single group
of people and we shouldn't punish any
single group of people but our firm gave
a presentation last februari and I think
we listed two full pages of what i call
the villains
well it at AIG AIG FP financial products
the swap sub to me financial products
was unique amongst the AIG subsidiaries
it was almost as if it was not a part of
AIG it was extremely independent and set
up to be that way and it also was I
think unique in that four of the holding
company directors were on the board of
AIG FP is mr. Greenberg and how we Smith
the CFO bruni aiden off retired from
Sullivan & Cromwell and Maddie Feldstein
I don't know when hank was pushed out
because I didn't have my relationship
with these people like they put their
arms out and kept kept me away as others
and they were successful in doing it
because Hank supported them being
separate I don't know what kind of
oversight was being carried on when we
were redoing the annual report in 2005
and afterwards I'm happy to say the
trades were put on after I left but I
wouldn't have known about it anyway the
way it was run and I also don't have a
full understanding of what happened with
risk management that AIG was perhaps one
of the few firms that had early on had
market risk at both the level of the
profit center and in the holding company
what did happen is that the senior
market rates market risk officer retired
there was a reorganization and he was
going to report to somebody and I think
he decided that he rather not report to
someone he had been reporting directly
to Hank and had a good rapport with Hank
and he had a feel for financial products
and he was tough enough to deal with
them with him gone I suspect we lost
some edge and with Hank gone we lost an
edge and so the thought about the
massive bailout because of the needs of
collateral you know I don't know why all
those trades were put on but what we're
seeing now is for many of them you know
that the risk was market value risk it
was the same thing as
long-term capital management you know at
aig berkshire hathaway and goldman sachs
were going to buy long-term capital
management's book it was the book would
be in the money at maturity it was baked
in the cake profit it just didn't have
the capital to get there and we got we
didn't get a chance to do the
transaction because of a meeting at the
new york fed in the same way i am
guessing now I don't know that financial
products book may well be in the money
yes they're probably something bad
credit default swaps but some of that
collateral was starting to come back so
it was the need for massive amounts that
the way FP ran is every transaction was
guaranteed by the holding company by a
IJ which was then Triple A which was
then double a and there were triggers in
the swaps so when AI GF we IG was
downgraded and affected FP put all of
those events together in the massive
needs for the collateral that the banks
were unwilling to put up maybe it was
just too much for them or they they
couldn't see it all but that was a shock
to the system in terms of size but not
as big a shock to the system is lehman I
mean I don't I don't I think AIG was
sort of gravy I think the real massive
amount was the the Lehman shock to the
system of the Lehman failure after the
bear stearns bailout
I think they were both had a mistaken
view and I think though the thought
really if I can recall being correctly
really is that the product could
withstand it that the investors who
invested in these products were all
mature adults able to invest by side
investors many of the triple-a tranches
were acquired by banking organizations
who thought they were safe even though
they end and they bought credit default
swap insurance on it I think there was
just too much of an assumption that the
product would take care of himself that
if there were defaults the people that
risk was spread the whole the whole
thought of credit default swap and
securitization was the spreading of risk
and I think what we've learned is yes
you can spread it but the other part of
it was you couldn't get rid of it
because of the lack of liquidity in the
market and I really see the major issue
in the major signal for me was early on
when there was no 30 60 90 day money in
the market and people with positions
couldn't finance themselves and I think
the Fed was a little slow to pick that
up but I think too much assuredness in
the product they'll be interesting to
see when when the product does come back
in a major way will it just come back
again in the same way that there won't
be any features on it that will yield
control in the banking organization so
that they can get these off
off-balance-sheet not have some of them
come back like there are coming back but
i but i think there was just too much of
an assumption that this product worked
but we and it probably you know I guess
we'd have to look back to the last
recession and say you know there really
weren't a lot of issues in housing of a
great degree securitize housing in the
last recession so we we lack the
experience and the major concern on
securitizations were in a market of
falling interest rates people doing
refinancing and we didn't see that in
this market perhaps we're seeing
now when when when people can do it but
I think the answer is to be a little
more skeptical of the product I'm
disappointed in the buy side we've had a
lot of criticism of the south side which
is deserve but a lot of the people
buying these products were institutional
investors